hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca I'm for integrity we talk about
the official rewards for season six
which include an emblem outline and a
bunch of ornaments like that
so with that like the view if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of a foreigner that
being passionate balance changes hero
updates new leaks all that stuff like
that and with that let's get started
with today's video the original link
with this will be down below if you want
to see for yourself credits a low [ __ ]
or low Fuji I don't know how to
pronounce this on reddit for posting
these I appreciate that dude but first
congratulate to the Vikings for winning
the faction war samurai got second and
the Knights came in last maybe next time
boys but first up is going to be the
outline and I am a knight so I got mine
at bronze if you're unfamiliar with how
the faction war works in terms of
outlines everyone gets the same outline
except the winners get gold the second
place gets silver and the third gets
bronze so you can kind of use your
imagination or check your own game to
see what color you got but the outline
isn't really that bad it's got a nice
gold gem at the top with some nice
intricate detailed designs going down
the bottom of the outline with the
figurehead of what looks like to be a
line at the bottom I personally like
this outline simply because it doesn't
cover too much of the emblem which is
nice if you do want to show off your
emblem in-game but continuing on we now
have the ornaments and if you're
unfamiliar with this part whoever wins
the faction more this time this being
the Vikings will get all the ornaments
for every single character no matter if
they're a knight samurai or viking see
your ornaments for every character in
the game but you can only equip them if
you're part of the winning faction like
I said that being the Vikings for this
season but the name of the ornament is
called serpentine kiss for all three
groups the knight version of the
ornament is alright it has some of it's
one of the smaller of the three which
we'll see a little bit later a big great
gem in the middle with some designs of
swirls going to the top of the piece not
a too crazy of an ornament but still
pretty cool regardless
next is the Vikings and by far my
favorite of the three this has a similar
gem in the front like before with bones
protruding out of the center of it which
looks pretty nice as well and I think
the black tips on the edge of the bones
will change color on the ornament but
I'm not 100% sure yet and lastly we have
the samurai which is the following the
same theme as that there's a similar gem
in the middle but this time in red this
will most likely change color depending
on the outfit but on top of that the
ornament has some fire at the top of
some other small details and two things
hanging off the side which I don't
really know what they are and yeah those
are gonna be the rewards for season 6
not a whole lot of course just in since
because we've never really had too many
rewards and the faction war but I think
these ornaments are pretty well and
they're slowly improving from the call
that we've had the past couple seasons
but the question of the video today is
gonna be what is your favorite armament
of the three and do you think these were
worth fighting for and if you think that
these are actually really good ornaments
as opposed to last season's of the past
couple seasons we've had so yeah with
that it's gonna be the end of the video
today guys like the V feed to enjoy
subscribe for new like I said a cover
the informational side of for longer
that being balance changes hero updates
news patch notes leaks all that good
stuff like that and with that my two
most recent videos will be on screen in
a bit if you guys want to check that out
with that guy stove a great yesterday
thank for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]